oh
15 août fête de l'assomption célébrée
dans le monde à paris deux processions
celle de l'église catholique mais aussi
celle des vins intégrer ceux qui ont
provoqué le shift convention
républicaine à new orleans george bush
joue son va tout pour convaincre les
électeurs
le président reagan lui a apporté son
soutien mais où est donc pauline lafont
l'inquiétude grandit 300 personnes dont
une centaine de légionnaires participent
maintenant aux recherches dans le maquis
du gard bonsoir il était sans doute
l'italien le plus connu dans le monde
il était aussi celui qui a fabriqué
quelques uns de nos plus beaux rêves
d'enfance enzo ferrari est mort hier à
90 ans
son nom n'était pas seulement celui
d'une marque automobile il était aussi
la griffe d'un grand créateur d'un
artiste pendant près de 50 ans et
voitures ont couru sur tous les circuits
du monde
presque tous les grands pilotes ont
conduit pour lui et ses voitures ou
gagner toutes les grandes courses
thierry blancot rétrospective qui n'en a
pas rêvé un jour quand la philosophie
d'un constructeur transforme un moyen de
transport en objets d'art le symbole
ferrari inaccessibles comme son
concepteur enzo ferrari était avant tout
un perfectionniste curieux destin
portant le commendatore détesté l'école
il voulait devenir chanteur d'opéra ou
encore chroniqueur sportif à l'âge de 18
ans fiat avait même refusé de
l'embaucher
et ça n'est qu'en 1920 qu'ils touchent
de près à l'automobile en entrant chez
alfa romeo
il fonde sa propre écurie neuf ans plus
tard en abandonnant très vite le
pilotage pour la préparation et la
construction de voitures de course
depuis 1947 ces bolides ont parcouru
tous les circuits 93 victoire en grand
prix
neuf titres mondiaux entre 1949 et 1965
neuf victoires au mans
si les les circonstances et dans
certaines circonstances
le pilote a une voiture qui favorise sa
victoire avril chez la souris tories
comme et wilson aura l'occasion dans
d'autres occasions c'est le pilote est
de la voiture à la mcl normalement ses
55 ans c'est une division parfaite des
mérites
à part jim clark jackie stewart ou alain
prost tous les grands du sport
automobile ont piloté les voitures
rouges de la scuderia lauda regazzoni x
ou encore jeudi schacter derniers
champions du monde pour ferrari en 1979
mais depuis la mort de son fils dino en
1956 enzo ferrari ne se rendaient
pratiquement plus sur les circuits la
passion payé au prix fort avec des amis
noirs
le terrible accident de l'odeur nom de
rouen 76 et surtout la mort de gilles
villeneuve pilote favori 182 à zolder
le commendatore ne sortait presque plus
de chez lui soigné à son domicile pour
troubles rénaux
ils n'avaient même pas pu rencontrer le
pape lors de sa visite à maranello en
juin dernier un monstre sacré de
l'automobile vient de disparaître
il nous reste ses modèles pour rêver
avec nous un pilote qui a remporté
quatre fois les 24 heures du mans sur
ferrari qui a piloté aussi en formule 1
pour ferrari toujours c'est olivier
gendebien le pilote belge bonsoir
olivier gendebien alors au delà de
l'hommage que tous les pilotes rendent à
ferrari ce soir quels souvenirs
gardez-vous de cette époque est ce que
c'est le souvenir d'une époque heureuse
je garde souvenait de n'est pas très
heureuse qui va permis de gagner pas mal
de corse et qui m'a fait rencontrer un
personnage qui avait un magnétisme
absolument extraordinaire et pourtant
tous les pilotes s'accordent pour dire
que les relations avec enzo ferrari
n'était pas toujours facile avait là je
suis assez d'accord mais les relations
avec lui est un très différente pour moi
du fait que je n'ai jamais demandé
d'entrer dracula et c'est lui qui m'a
demandé mais il y avait d'autres cas
comme ça et ça n'a pas empêché pourtant
certains pilotes après d'être renvoyés
sévèrement disons 'peut-être je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait d'autres cas comparable
mais comment vous comment s'était passée
votre arrivée chez ferrari vient ferrari
aurait été en fait rien à voir avec les
que contre lui parce que je vais bâtir
avec ma voiture personnelle et j'ai
trouvé que je risquais de dangereux dans
une équipe et quand vous êtes arrivé
chez ferrari vous avez l'impression
vraiment d'entrer dans une très grande
équipe c'était pour vous c'était quoi
en réalité j'ai l'impression de ne plus
savoir compter croyant être celle quand
j'ai compté des formules al-faraj
j'étais je n'ose pas pousser à francs
soit à l'époque ferrari avait déjà un
très grand prestige à 2h l'époque il
était sur pied du monde
c'était là l'équipe prestigieuse mais à
vaduz - département compte alors vous
thaler que vous gardiez un souvenir très
heureux de cette époque mais pourtant
tous les pilotes s'accordent pour dire
que les relations avec enzo ferrari tu
tournes m a fait difficiles les
relations intercell dans le sens que ce
que je reprochais la maison c'était de
mettre les pilotes de la même équipe
arrivée était l'un de l'autre et ça
n'est pas tellement passé dans une dans
une équipe de corps cette ville qu'on le
fasse en boxe à cames encore cet avis je
suis pas d'accord j'ai l'impression
qu'ils ont ferrari préféré ces voitures
ou ses pilotes
les impatients que ils préfèrent ils
disaient que pouvoir le ps
je crois qu'ils préfèrent la voiture
merci olivier gendebien et c'est vrai il
faut le dire l'histoire de la scuderia
ferrari a été marquée par les relations
tumultueuses entre le commendatore et
ses pilotes de fangio alauda de fille
lila jacky ickx tous ont dû subir à un
moment ou un autre les foudres du patron
enzo ferrari de son côté quand il a
écrit un livre de souvenirs là intitulé
les pilotes
quelle race témoignage d'un autre pilote
qui a couru pour ferrari très récemment
c'est patrick tambay reportage éric
perrin silverstone cette année deux
ferrari en première ligne burger et
alboreto image rare cette saison
pourtant au sommet ou non la scuderia
toujours été une étape marquante
sinon un aboutissement dans la carrière
d'un pilote patrick tambay a couru deux
saisons chez ferrari en 82 et en 83
j'avoue que toute ma période chez eux
représentant
24 grands prix un an et demi sera un
souvenir dans son ensemble très très
marquant pour moi en tout cas comme
comme pilote de grand prix je crois que
c'est absolument indéniable et il ya un
ensemble de deux sentiments de choses
qui en font quelque chose de très
important pour moi c'est
vraisemblablement la fin d'un chapitre
très important de l'histoire de l'écurie
ferrari maintenant quel sera son avenir
bon je pense que avec la présence du
groupe fiat et puis depuis déjà pas mal
de temps cette situation était envisagée
sera certainement mise en place est déjà
probablement mise en place une une
stratégie politique qui assurera la
continuité de l'écurie ferrari dans le
sport automobile mondial déjà et puis
sur le plan industriel
vous l'avez connu quel type d'homme
était-il un homme
très strictes intransigeant pour le
travail aussi bien de ses ingénieurs de
ses mécaniciens que de ses pilotes très
très rigoureux machiavélique parfois un
peu florentin est aussi quelqu'un de
très bons quelqu'un de de très pertinent
sur celle analyses techniques ou
sportives de situation généralement très
très difficile il a connu beaucoup de
joies dans la course automobile et aussi
beaucoup de peine mais quelqu'un donc à
qui a su souffrir qui a qui a souffert
et donc quelqu'un de très sensible 15
août fête de l'assomption célébrée par
toute l'église catholique à rome jean
paul ii a solennellement clos l'année
mariale à saint pierre de rome
il a remis la perspective du troisième
millénaire à l'intercession de la femme
vierge la vierge marie célébrée aussi
par les catholiques français cette année
il y avait deux processions à paris d'un
côté les fidèles de l'église catholique
qui voulaient manifester leur ferveur
de l'autre les intégristes ceux qui ont
rompu avec l'église il y à un mois et
demi
il représente beaucoup moins deux
chrétiens mais ils ont voulu eux aussi
montré leur force
pascal deschamps rémy roche pas de
surprise sur le parvis de notre-dame dix
mille catholiques fidèles au pape est
fidèle au rendez-vous l'histoire car il
ya 350 ans louis xiii faisait don de sa
personne et de la france à la mère de
dieu depuis 738 le 15 août et donc une
fête légale chômé pour tous mais surtout
l'occasion pour les catholiques de se
retrouver et de rendre grâce à la vierge
un lion aux arènes de lutèce où s'arrête
au même moment l'autre procession un
lion pour témoigner du martyr dont
furent victimes des millions de
catholiques aux débuts de l'église
allusion non voilée aux persécutions
dont s'estime à nouveau frappé des
catholiques traditionalistes il dit au
moins 5000 fidèles de monseigneur
lefebvre pour fêter l'assomption dans
les rues du quartier latin
la première grande célébration depuis le
schisme prononcée par le vatican à la
suite de la consécration en juin ah et
comme de quatre évêques intégristes dont
monseigneur tissier de mallerais
participer à la procession ya pas de
schisme et les fidèles restent attachés
au saint siège et au saint père il
estime que dans le fond de son coeur
certainement de saint père ne peut pas
être opposé à la continuation de la
tradition un autre dame on ne veut ni
ignorer la procession rival ni en
surestimer l'importance
l'ambiance est plutôt à la tristesse
mais aussi à l'espoir de voir tout le
monde réuni l'an prochain très intéressé
par de graves je ne peux que prier pour
ceux qui s'enfonce dans une séparation
qui n'a pas beaucoup de sens car la
seule chose que nous puissions faire
comme catholiques c'est de prier pour
que ceux-ci ne choque pas les incroyants
ou qu'on ne comprennent pas grand chose
et que ça ne leur fasse pas trouvé
ridicule notre notre affirmation de la
force de l'amour et de la paix du pardon
discours modéré mais attitude tranche et
il faut bien constater ce soir que le
fossé entre les deux communautés
certes d'inégal important c'est encore
un peu plus creusé la difficile semaine
de george bush la convention
républicaine s'est ouverte à la nouvelle
orléans
le vice président bush qui est assurée
de l'investiture de son parti le parti
républicain depuis mars dernier va
tenter en moins d'une semaine de
convaincre les électeurs américains et
pas seulement les républicains il doit
montrer qu'il a la stature d'un
président ce que beaucoup lui conteste
hier soir le président reagan a apporté
son soutien à monsieur bush
jacquat bouchard regan sur le front des
troupes ultime parade pour reggane
on hésite entre le langage militaire et
le jargon du spectacle pour qualifier le
dernier tour de piste du président à la
nouvelle orléans une apparition en tout
cas réussi propre à galvaniser les
délégués républicains a couru de tout le
pays
ronald reagan a planté les premières
banderilles et fait couler un peu de
sang démocrates en qualifiant de
mascarade la récente convention
démocrate atlanta armé d'un marteau
géant il a promis de mettre ko le parti
de l'âne alors que son auditoire plein
de nostalgie lui demandait de jouer les
prolongations à la maison blanche
mais après huit années d'antichambre
george bush va enfin pouvoir jouer avec
ses propres cartes at il des atouts
maîtres c'est évidemment toute la
question
beaucoup dépendra du choix de son numéro
deux le candidat vice président en tout
cas george bush retrouve un certain
tonus après des moments difficiles le
mois dernier dans les sondages il se
traînait 17 points derrière dukakis et
le voilà trois points devant
selon un sondage de la chaîne de
télévision abc seul point noir pour le
candidat républicain
les femmes continuent de le bouder quoi
qu'il en soit les démocrates font la
grimace
peut-être avait-il vendu un peu tôt la
peau de l'ours
je devrais dire d'ailleurs de l'éléphant
républicain au fait pourquoi ce
pachyderme pour symboliser le parti de
lincoln
il serait né sous le crayon d'un carré
clitoris qui lie à une centaine d'années
un caricaturiste qui voulait illustrer
la force et la puissance des
républicains et pourquoi l'un démocrate
et bien parce que ils ont beau vouloir
ressembler à un lion ils ne sont que des
add ceci est évidemment une explication
peu flatteuse que va donner un
républicain et je lui enlève toute la
responsabilité
la corée du sud à un mois des jeux
aujourd'hui le gouvernement de séoul a
essayé de désamorcer la crise qui couve
depuis plusieurs semaines le président
sud coréen a proposé tout à l'heure de
rencontrer son homologue nord coréen
il espère ainsi mettre un terme aux
affrontements très violents ce lundi
1300 étudiants ont été arrêtés
isabelle bechler sur le campus de
l'université de yonsei à séoul il ne
faisait pas bon manifesté pour la
réunification de la corée aujourd'hui
1300 étudiants en tirant en ce moment
même les enseignements à l'hôpital ou en
prison
ce qu'il voulait en ce jour anniversaire
de l'armistice de la seconde guerre
mondiale c'était aller à la rencontre de
leurs camarades de la corée du nord pour
évoquer la réunification de la nation
coréenne
le rendez vous était pris sur la
frontière au village de panmunjom en
pleine zone démilitarisée mais la police
du sud a rempli sa mission
barrer la route aux gros des étudiants
de co2 du nord n'ont pas eu les mêmes
problèmes
au contraire le régime socialiste de kim
il sung les encourageait les j'encadrais
depuis une semaine dans leur longue
marche dans la frontière entre les deux
corées le nord apparemment ouvert à la
négociation le nord qui s'est engagé à
ne pas gâcher la fête des jeux
olympiques de séoul le nord dont on
pense pourtant qu'ils manipulent
activement les étudiants pour cette fête
sont effet terres du sud le même nord
qui n'a pas encore répondu à la main
tendue du président fouta au bout amman
en jordanie fin de la rencontre entre
les autorités jordaniennes et les
représentants palestiniens
c'est la première fois qu'ils se
rencontraient depuis la décision du roi
hussein sur la cisjordanie selon les
deux délégations cela devrait permettre
le renforcement du rôle de l'ol paie au
niveau international dans les
territoires occupés par israël justement
nouveaux troubles un palestinien a été
tué en cisjordanie à gaza
le couvre-feu est institué depuis deux
jours jérusalem charles enderlin l'armée
isrélienne n'arrive pas à imposer le
couvre-feu à gaz en dépit des ordres du
commandement militaire ces femmes sont
sortis de leurs maisons pour affronter
les soldats
le bouclage du secteur est totale les
ouvriers palestiniens ne peuvent
toujours pas se rendre à leur lieu de
travail en israël et les journalistes ne
circule dans gaza qu accompagner par un
officier de liaison
j'ai deux mille colons installés à gaza
l'atmosphère est tendue après l'incident
d'hier soir six israéliens dont un bébé
ont été blessées par un cocktail molotov
l'armée a lancé les appels au calme aux
habitants des implantations
la tension monte également cisjordanie
où plusieurs localités sont sous couvre
feu
les responsables de l'administration
israélienne attribuent ce regain
d'agitation aux informations sur
d'éventuelles initiatives politiques de
l'ol paie et notamment la création d'un
gouvernent
même en palestiniens dans les
territoires en tout cas la réaction
israélienne sera très ferme dit-on dans
les milieux gouvernementaux de jérusalem
pas question de permettre à
l'organisation de yasser arafat de
prendre pied en cisjordanie les
palestiniens eux s'apprête à durcir leur
lutte
en attendant la réunion des instances
politiques de l'ol paie l'irlande du
nord depuis plusieurs semaines les
terroristes irlandais ont intensifié
leurs actions ils ne comptent pas
s'arrêter là ils ont dit qu'ils allaient
continuer de s'attaquer aux soldats
britanniques de préférence à l'étranger
car les répercussions médiatiques selon
eux sont beaucoup plus fortes
gilles rabin ces centaines de soldats
britanniques déployés dans les rues
pauvres de belfast ouest pour isoler la
manifestation des catholiques irlandais
et empêcher toute heure avec les
protestants ont pu entendre de leurs
propres oreilles
le numéro deux du sing faye la branche
politique de l'ira annoncé que les
attentats et les meurtres de soldats
britanniques allaient s'intensifier dans
toute l'europe
nous avons vu les bataillons de l'ira en
allemagne en belgique et en hollande dit
l'orateur faisant allusion au meurtre
d'un soldat anglais à ostende
vendredi dernier ils parlent pour nous
ces combattants de la liberté de la
seule façon que les britanniques
comprennent
depuis le début de l'année lire a
provoqué la mort de 18 soldats
britanniques pour l'armée de l'arenh
c'est le plus lourd bilan depuis 71 72
les années noires de la loi sur
l'internement sans jugement que ce défi
les catholiques irlandais commémore
voyons maintenant le reste de
l'actualité internationale avec nicolas
jacobs les étapes ce soir khartoum
kaboul
varsovie new york
l'aide internationale parvient
difficilement aux victimes des
inondations 1200 tonnes de vivres de
médicaments et de matériel sont arrivés
sur l'aéroport de khartoum mais ne sont
distribuées au compte gouttes
en cause les difficultés de transport
mais aussi l'armée qui veut assurer seul
la distribution
communiqué de victoire du pays dans
hadjibou là le numéro afghan annonce que
les gouvernementaux ont repris à la
guérilla la ville de koundouz dans le
nord du pays
mais cette même guérilla salue cette
déclaration en tirant des roquettes sur
kaboul l'armée soviétique elle continue
à se retirer comme prévu la moitié des
troupes a déjà quitté le pays
en inde reggane mirail gorbatchev à
nouveau réunis en septembre prochain
c'est ce qu'affirme une revue américaine
ce cinquième sommet américano soviétique
aurait lieu à new york à l'occasion de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu
pour l'instant ni le kremlin ni la
maison blanche n'ont confirmé cette
nouvelle
une confirmation des discussions vont
commencer cette semaine à paris sur la
nouvelle calédonie il y aura une
délégation du rpcr il y aura aussi une
délégation du fln ksl sera complète avec
des représentants de toutes les
principales composantes en corse le flnc
fait de nouveau parler de lui il a fait
irruption sur la scène du spectacle de
clôture des journées nationaliste de
corte devant 3000 personnes pour lire un
message public
gilles leclair cagoule treillis
militaire mais pas d'armes
c'est peu après minuit la nuit dernière
que cinq militants se réclamant de l'ex
flnc font irruption sous le chapiteau
des journées de l'unité nationale il n'y
aura pas d'incident devant 3000
personnes
l'un des hommes lit d'une longue
déclaration de cinq pages ton modéré
appel au dialogue
l'ex flnc demande au gouvernement d
solution politique au problème corse
c'est la troisième fois depuis le 31 mai
dernier
depuis l'annnonce de sa trêve de quatre
mois que le mouvement indépendantiste
cherche ainsi à communiquer une façon
d'illustrer une possible nouvelle
stratégie visant d'abord à améliorer
l'image de l'ex été lancé auprès des
corses eux mêmes ensuite en souhaitant
visiblement une concertation avec les
autres mouvements plus modérée enfin à
faire un geste en direction du
gouvernement à qui il est demandé
maintenant des réponses politiques
pauline lafont toujours introuvable cela
fait maintenant quatre jours que la
comédienne a disparue dans le gard
accident ou bien alors fugue ou coup de
pub même aucune hypothèse n'est écartée
par les policiers
les recherches en tout cas en reprit 300
personnes dont une centaine de
légionnaires cherche la comédienne dans
le maquis sur place dans le gard patrice
blais mobilisation autour de la maison
dès la fonte gendarmes et militaires de
150 hommes environ ratissage
systématique des chiens un hélicoptère
des plongeurs les grands moyens
la décision est tombée en fin de matinée
reprise des recherches
un ordre venu d'en haut effectivement
vous savez que déjà de ratissage ont eu
lieu durant la journée de samedi et à
défaut de lenovo
il faut que nous soyons coisy certains
qui ne se trouvent pas de personnes
blessées dans cette zone et qu'il aurait
pas eu de secours et c'est donc la
raison pour laquelle les ratissages avec
un très grand renfort de personnel ont
été effectués durant cette journée
fausse piste pour les enquêteurs pas de
résultats mais il fallait en avoir le
coeur net
ce soir le mec qui a gardé son secret
s'il en détient 1 vous croyez qu'on peut
se perdre dans ces montagnes dans nos
langues tempo silhouette ne s'était pas
que c'est impossible ans tout se perd
manquent pas il ya trop de un taux de
gens qui circulent dans l'écouté de
l'autre et en tas de gens de promeneurs
de mais par contre tous il est arrivé
quelque chose qu'elles soient tombés
fous rires comment ces fous et on peut
passer à côté de 102 m ehpad arepa la
part avoir et ça c'est sûr
allez savoir c'est difficile mais moi je
sois dans la montagne au nord
les recherches pourraient se poursuivre
demain déjà cinq jours d'attenté au
coeur de l'été à
saint-andré-de-valborgne l'espoir
s'amenuisait le mystère reste entier
football l'équipe qu'on attendait pas
depuis samedi le championnat de france a
de nouveau à part dont un nouveau leader
unique c'est toulon avant la saison on
prévoyait une mainmise des équipes nast
aux deux genres marseille bordeaux ou
monaco et bien elles ne sont pas très
loin mais toulon tient tête et tiens
donc
dominique le glou portrait d'une équipe
sans complexe
l'histoire avec un grand h retient de
toulon le sabordage de la flotte en
novembre 40 de l'histoire avec un petit
h retient du football les crises
successives qui ont failli couler le
sporting club de toulon
les entraîneurs succédant aux
entraîneurs jusqu'à l'arrivée de rolland
courbis précédé d'une bien mauvaise
réputation de bagarreur ce que je posais
à gaza je ne faisais pas avec
et caetera haddock
on peut penser comme par pas les
prochains jeux des faits qui lui manque
peut-être ses dernières années
j'ai cherché mais est ce pas tout
simplement que j'évite deux ans plus
tard on lui attribue toutes les qualités
il a sauvées too long de la descente
puis l'a conduit à la cinquième place du
championnat avant la position de leaders
d'aujourd'hui
en deux saisons il s'est refait une
image osmose avec une ville qui se
transforme chicago le quartier chaud ses
rondeurs qui sait bientôt du passé
une image néanmoins qui colle encore un
peu trop à la ville comme toutes ces
mauvaises réputations elle sereine
longtemps après qu'elles étaient
justifiées elles ne sont utiles si fier
sa réputation là toulon est une ville
qui travaillent qui a de l'ambition qui
veut gagner qui veut gagner au pas
simplement en sport donc tout est où se
tient le sport le redressement
économique de la cité tout ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui à toulon les jeux de
ballons remplacer les jeunes mains
l'euphorie aidant tout l'on accède pour
la première fois de son histoire à la
première phase du championnat
une surprise pour certains qui avaient
dû oublier la cinquième place de l'an
dernier joseph antoine bell lui le
savait on rejoignons toulon il a trouvé
la sérénité est ainsi reconduit
merci de masse et à partir du mans m'a
fait me ressemble est de moins en moins
et donc je suis arrivé à tout vent c'est
bien que toulon face des choses qui me
conviennent si un jour toulon ne le
ferai plus il est certain que j'aurais
du mal à rester et oui on ne se sent
bien qu avec les gens avec qui l'on
partage quelque chose histoire d'amour
ou d'identification
joseph antoine est un modèle son fils
fait tout pour lui ressembler et si
demain tout l'on pouvait ressembler à
joseph-antoine sa mauvaise réputation
serait définitivement oubliée
pourquoi
il y avait un tiercé quarté +
aujourd'hui c'était à deauville alors
voici l'ordre d'arrivée 18 17 haas et 9
pour le quarté alors 18-17 à ça c'est le
tiercé dans l'ordre 25000 43 100 et 50
centimes le quarté + maintenant voilà 18
17 h 9 très gros carpes et très gros
tiers ses 153 milles 55 francs et 20
centimes dans l'ordre exact pour ce
quarté + de deauville fin de ce journal
merci d'être resté avec nous tout de
suite vous avez rendez vous avec laurent
cabrol pour une météo complète la
dernière édition du journal le prochain
rendez vous avec l'information donc ce
sera vers 23h50 assez tard avec philippe
lefait bonne soirée à demain